talk to me about um
you know
coming out of a group right shoreline
mafia i feel like kind of paved the way
for a lot of the uh la [ __ ] that's going
on right now for sure most days um
you know i think of like draco greedo
and you guys that kind of like laid the
foundation for a lot of the scene right
now you know what i mean
um
how hard was it for you to kind of pivot
away from the group or was it kind of
always in the in the plans because
anybody was like a fan of what you guys
are doing
you know
you you were i mean i mean shout out to
everybody in the group but but i think
it was obvious that like eventually you
had to go solo or at least i feel like
it was it was never in the plan it's
just like you know people people grow
like and just being on tour being on the
road just figuring out life like i'm
getting older i had my kid when i had my
kid i was like you know what this like
maybe it's time for me to go do my own
thing
so but everybody felt like that
everybody was like yeah we want to do
our own thing yeah i think too when you
got so many people involved in trying to
get to the same thing right everybody's
got to be aligned everyone's energy's
got to match each other
everyone's effort
and
you know
that's why it's so hard for groups to
work man yeah yeah so you got to think
it's four different opinions four
different energies four personalities
that's a that's a lot going on